es ist 3 Uhr an diesem Morgen Vikor
Orban verlässt diesen Gipfeltag der zwei
Botschaften bringt für ihn volodomir
selenski hatte sich gestern zugeschaltet
stellte seinen Auftritt ins Netz und
warnte vor einem
Scheitern putin wird das natürlich gegen
sie persönlich nutzen und gegen ganz
Europa schenken Sie ihm nicht seinen
ersten und einzigen Sieg in diesem
Jahr
so gibt es eine gute Botschaft für die
Ukraine den Beginn von
Beitrittsverhandlungen es ist ein
historischer Moment er zeigt die
Glaubwürdigkeit und die Stärke der
Europäischen
Union gestern Morgen sah es danach nicht
aus da wartet Viktor auban auf seinen
Platz vor den Mikros da droht Ungarns
premier noch mit einem
Veto
die EU-Kommission sagt dass drei von
sieben Vorbedingungen nicht erfüllt sind
wir brauchen das also gar nicht erst zu
bereden offene Bedingungen gibt es bei
der
Korruptionsbekämpfung dem Einfluss von
Oligarchen und dem Schutz nationaler
Minderheiten außer Orban Vertrauen alle
darauf die Ukraine werde nacharbeiten
und stimmen zu auf deutschen Vorschlag
hin hatte Orban vor der Abstimmung den
Saal verlassen und tritt kurz darauf
Video nach Beitrittsverhandlungen sein
sinnlos doch in seinem Fall kein nein
auch ein
ja wenn du zustimmst musst du danach
deinen Mund halten das hätte ich nicht
sagen
sollen denn es gibt auch diese Botschaft
50 Milliarden Euro der EU für die
Ukraine da blockiert Ungarn ein Foto
lässt ahnen warumb Minister spielen in
der Hand auf 31 Milliarden Euro an Geld
dass die EU wegen Mängeln in Ungarns
Justiz sperrte und ausgerechnet
vorgestern teilweise freigab
Ungarn verbindet seine Probleme nicht
mit denen der Ukraine das ist nicht
unser
Stil und doch bleibt er bei seinem
vetto das war wir sagen wie es ist 26
Länder sind sich einig aber es gibt noch
keine Zustimmung von
Ungarn Wiedervorlage voraussichtlich
noch im Januar solange muss die Ukraine
warten
mindestens wir gehen nach Brüssel zu
Florian neuhahn hat den Gipfel gestern
verfolgt beitrittsverhandlung wird's
jetzt geben aber die können natürlich
lange dauern die dringend benötigten 50
Milliarden für die Ukraine die sind aber
blockiert florian war die Zustimmung
Orbans zu den Beitrittsverhandlungen
jetzt der größere Erfolg für die
EU na ja diese Eröffnung von
beitrittsverhandlung ist erstmal nur ein
Symbol eine kurze Etappe in einem langen
Marathon bis hin zum möglichen
EU-Beitritt der Ukraine irgendwann aber
man darf die Bedeutung dieses Symbols
wohl nicht unterschätzen erst recht wenn
man auf die euphorischen Reaktionen aus
der Ukraine schaut die ja dringend
Motivation braucht kurz vor dem zweiten
Kriegswinter auf der anderen Seite wäre
glaube ich die finanzielle Hilfe
langfristig für die Ukraine und auch
kurzfristig deutlich wichtiger die
Ukraine braucht dieses Geld dringend
kann ohne dieses Geld wohl nicht
überleben und 50 Milliarden Euro das
wäre so etwas wie eine
Sicherheitsgarantie über die ja seit
Wochen eigentlich immer wieder geredet
wird aber die anderen 26 EU-Staaten
wollen da jetzt nicht aufgeben man macht
zweierlei setzt einerseits auf einen
wohl nächsten EU Sondergipfel
voraussichtlich noch im Januar und hofft
dann Ungarn auf die Seite zu ziehen und
falls das nicht gelingt dann höre ich
gibt es bereits einen Plan B dann
nämlich könne man auch diese Hilfen zu
26 beschließen außerhalb des
EU-Haushaltes ohne Ungarn das wäre
aufwendig aber so so heißt es es wäre
möglich und so will Europa auch Vikor
aubann hier die Grenzen aufzeigen dann
sagen wir vielen Dank nach Brüssel
Florian neuhahn und sprechen hier jetzt
im Studio weiter und zwar mit Norbert
röttken CDU außenexperte einen schönen
guten Morgen Herr rötken ein guten
Morgen also Beitrittsverhandlungen ja
Ukraine Hilfen nein und alles wegen
Viktor Orban dem man zuvor eingefrorene
eu-milliarden freigegeben hatte was
denken Sie ich denke dass
wir uns klarer werden müssen was Orban
eigentlich will Orban ist nicht mehr nur
ein Erpresser der zu Hause Demokratie
und Rechtsstaat abschafft und übrigens
dann der Ukraine die im Krieg ist
vorwirft sie sei nicht vorbereitet für
die Europäische Union es ist an Zynismus
nicht zu überbieten ich glaube dass
Orban inzwischen ein anderes Projekt hat
er will diese Europäische Union wie sie
ist als demokratische rechtsstaatliche
Europäische Union zerstören er ist ein
Bündnispartner von Wladimir Putin der
Krieg führt gegen die Ukraine mit der
jetzt Beitritt verhandelt wird Orban hat
erklärt das hält er für falsch er hat
noch endlos Möglichkeiten das zu
torpedieren zu frustrieren und er nimmt
der Europäischen Union immer mehr
Legitimität indem er sie immer wieder
aufhält und Ergebnisse verhindert über
die Rolle von Ungarn aber auch die von
der EU können wir gleich noch mal
auffächern sprechen wissen sie wem
dieser Teilerfolg eigentlich zu
verdanken ist welchem
Mann der teil jetzt die
EUR der Teil Erfolg dass er rausgegangen
ist ich habe gehört dass der
Bundeskanzler Scholz im vorgeschlagen
hat doch mal rauszugehen ob das also ob
wurde jetzt üinstimm glaub ich wurde so
berichtet aber der Kern ist glaube ich
dass das Orban sich entschieden hat dass
er das nicht aufhalten will ich glaube
der Akteur dieser ganzen Veranstaltung
ist vktor Orban nicht Olaf Scholz nicht
irgendein anderer ich glaube die hat ja
auch hat 10 Milliarden raus geholt durch
sein Verhalten das ist ziemlich viel
dafür dass man mal Kaffee trinken geht
also 26 Milliarden sind noch eingefroren
für Ungarn das muss man auch natürlich
natürlich er hat aber ja auch nichts
verändert an den Gründen warum die
Mittel eingefroren worden sind nämlich
Abbau und abschaffen von Rechtsstaat und
Demokratie aber Scholz war der der
gesagt hat geh doch mal Kaffee trinken
das hat er gemacht ich glaube die
Entscheidung Kaffee trinken zu gehen hat
Orban gefällt das stimmt schon aber er
hat natürlich da wie sie eigentlich
schon gesagt haben auch natürlich seine
hinter Gedanken gehabt was bedeutet
jetzt dieses Ergebnis für die EU und was
für die
Ukraine das ist das ist zu den
Beitrittsverhandlungen jetzt kommt dass
sie eröffnet sind ist nicht ist auch
symbolisch aber mehr es ist ein
rechtlicher Akt das jetzt verhandelt
wird und das ist ein starkes Signal der
Europäischen Union der 26 dass die
Zukunft der Ukraine in Europa liegt das
ist es warum dieser Krieg geführt wird
warum Putin die Ukraine angreift weil
sie europäisch werden will und das ist
das ist total wichtig aber es ist noch
ein langer Weg dass Orban gleichzeitig
das Geld gesperrt hat zeigt wie mühsam
es wird gleichzeitig das ist auch kein
Zufall haben die Republikaner im
amerikanischen Kongress die Hilfen für
die Ukraine gesperrt 60 Milliarden und
die Ukraine ist in einer sowohl
militärisch wie jetzt auch
wirtschaftlich sehr sehr schwierigen
Lage und Daum ist hoch problematisch
ohne diese Wirtschaftshilfen droht der
Ukraine tatsächlich ein ein ein ein
Crash
glauben Sie denn dass das Geld auch so
zusammenkommt das ist ja so eine Art
Plan B ja das muss auch zunehmend so
geschehen dass die EU die gesamte EU die
27 nicht immer sich nur von einem
aufhalten lassen können es wird dann die
Mittel geben durch Beschluss der 26
Nationalstaaten
die dann als Staaten Handeln es ist
komplizierter aber es wird stattfinden
weil es sein muss wir können
aus historischem Verständnis aus
Empathie und aus eigenen Interessen äh
die Ukraine nicht hängen lassen das ist
unsere Sicherheit in Europa um die es
geht und um die werden wir kämpfen indem
wir die EU indem wir Ukraine
unterstützen das werden die 26 machen
Herr rötken sie haben mit diversen
prominenten gerade einen offenen Brief
formuliert indem sie noch stärkere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine fordern
nun hat der Kanzler ja so eben die
Ukraine Hilfen verdoppelt hat das jetzt
noch mal sozusagen unterfüttert und
glaubhaft gemacht reicht das jetzt nicht
aus also erstmal ist was im Haushalt
steht und was abfließt immer noch mal
was anderes aber ich begrüße das das
verdoppelt wird verdoppelt heißt auch es
war bislang nicht so wirklich viel wir
müssen es wir müssen einfach die
Realität sehen das was die Aufgabe ist
und wir sehen dass jetzt ein ein eine
militärische Pats Situation ist die
darauf die die Gefahr birgt dass die
Ukraine ausblutet Putin hat auf ein eine
Kriegswirtschaft umgestellt und
deutschland kann mehr hätte schon mehr
gekonnt schon lange wir haben den
marschflurkörper Tauros der ganz
wesentlich ist dafür dass die Ukraine
ihre Verteidigungsfähigkeit erhöht der
Bundeskanzler weigert sich ohne
Begründung diese extrem wirksame Waffe
der Ukraine zu geben das heißt dass wir
diese Lage haben das drohende ausbluten
ein Krieg ja überhaupt nur auf dem
Territorium des angegriffenen Staates äh
da das liegt entscheidend an der
mangelnden Unterstützung durch die
westlichen Staaten ist Deutschland V
allen voranzunennen aber auch die USA
das ist eine offensive die die Ukraine
führen ohne Luftunterstützung ohne
weitreichende Waffen das ist praktisch
unmöglich und das hat politische
Konsequenzen humanitäre Sterben Tod und
politische Lösungen werden immer weiter
weggeschoben und da ist ja noch dieses
Damokles Schwert in dieser Angelegenheit
namens Donald Trump wir wissen nicht was
da noch kommt aber die Beitritts die
jetzt auf den Weg gebracht sind das ist
zu begrüßen obwohl es da noch Störfeuer
aus Budapest zu erwarten gibt das sagt
Norbert röke CDU außenexerte vielen Dank
für den Besuch danke ihen
sehr